para escanear el medio ambiente.
Detecta las características del entorno,
y determina dónde está en relación con esas características,
utilizando un método de triangulación.
Entonces puede reunir todas estas características en un mapa,
como se ve detrás de mí.
Este mapa permite que el robot comprenda dónde están los obstáculos
y navegar libre de colisiones.
Lo que quiero mostrarles a continuación
es un conjunto de experimentos que hicimos en nuestro laboratorio,
en los que este robot fue capaz de ir a distancias más largas.
Verán, en la parte superior derecha, lo que el robot ve con la cámara.
En la pantalla principal
--por supuesto acelerado por un factor de cuatro--
verán el mapa que está construyendo.
Este es un mapa de alta resolución del corredor de nuestro laboratorio.
En un minuto verán que entra en nuestro laboratorio,
que es reconocible por el desorden que se ve.
(Risas)
Pero el punto que quiero transmitirles
es que estos robots son capaces de construir mapas de alta resolución
a resoluciones de 5 cm,
permitiendo a alguien que esté fuera del laboratorio, o fuera del edificio
realizarlos sin tener que entrar,
y tratar de inferir lo que sucede en el interior del edificio.
Hay un problema con los robots como éste.
El primer problema es que es bastante grande.
Como es grande, es pesado.
Y estos robots consumen alrededor de 220 vatios por kilo,
que hace su tiempo de misión muy corto.
El segundo problema
es que estos robots tienen sensores a bordo que terminan siendo muy caros:
un escáner láser, una cámara y los procesadores.
Eso aumenta el costo de este robot.
Así que nos hicimos una pregunta:
¿qué productos de consumo se pueden comprar en una tienda de electrónica
que sean de bajo costo, ligeros, que hagan detección a bordo y computación?
E inventamos el teléfono volador.
(Risas)
Este robot utiliza un Samsung Galaxy que se puede comprar comercialmente,
y todo lo que se necesita es una aplicación descargable en nuestra tienda.
Se puede ver a este robot leyendo las letras, "TED" en este caso,
mirando las esquinas de la "T" y la "E"
y luego triangulando eso, volando de forma autónoma.
Esa palanca está ahí para asegurar que si el robot se vuelve loco,
Giuseppe puede matarlo.
(Risas)
Además de la construcción de estos pequeños robots,
también experimentamos con comportamientos agresivos, como ven aquí.
Este robot está ahora viajando a dos o tres m por segundo,
con cabeceo y balanceo agresivo, ya que cambia de dirección.
El punto principal es que podemos tener robots más pequeños que vayan más rápido
y luego viajar en estos ambientes muy desestructurados.
En el siguiente video,
igual que vemos esta ave, un águila, coordinando con gracia sus alas,
sus ojos y pies para agarrar presas fuera del agua,
nuestro robot puede ir a pescar, también.
(Risas)
En este caso, un embutido que está agarrado de la nada.
Pueden ver este robot que va a unos 3 m por segundo,
más rápido que la velocidad al caminar, coordinando sus brazos, sus garras
y su vuelo en fracciones de segundo para lograr esta maniobra.
En otro experimento,
Quiero mostrar cómo el robot adapta su vuelo
para controlar su carga suspendida,
cuya longitud es en realidad mayor que la anchura de la ventana.
Para lograr esto,
en realidad tiene que lanzar y ajustar la altitud
y oscilar la carga.
Por supuesto, queremos hacer esto aún menor,
y estamos inspirados en particular por las abejas.
Si nos fijamos en las abejas, y este es un vídeo ralentizado,
son tan pequeñas, la inercia es tan ligera
(Risas)
que no les importa, rebotan en mi mano, por ejemplo.
Este es un pequeño robot que imita a las abejas.
Y más pequeño es mejor,
porque junto con el pequeño tamaño se obtiene más baja inercia.
Junto con menor inercia
(Robot zumbando, risas)
junto con una menor inercia, se es resistente a colisiones.
Y eso te hace más fuerte.
Así como estas abejas, construimos pequeños robots.
Este en particular es de solo 25 gr peso.
Consume solo 6 vatios de potencia.
Y puede viajar hasta a 6 m por segundo.
Si lo normalizo a su tamaño,
es como un Boeing 787 viajando a 10 veces la velocidad del sonido.
(Risas)
Quiero mostrarles un ejemplo.
Esta es probablemente la primera colisión en vuelo planeado, a una vigésima de la velocidad normal.
Estos van a una velocidad relativa de 2 m por segundo,
y esto ilustra el principio básico.
La jaula de fibra de carbono de 2 gr impide que las hélices se enreden,
pero en esencia la colisión es absorbida y el robot responde a las colisiones.
Y muy pequeño también significa seguro.
En mi laboratorio, al desarrollar estos robots,
comenzamos con estos grandes robots
y luego ahora bajamos a estos pequeños robots.
Si se traza un histograma del número de banditas que pedimos
en el pasado, mostraría un cola disminuyendo. (Risas)
Porque estos robots son muy seguros.
El tamaño pequeño tiene algunas desventajas,
y la naturaleza ha encontrado formas de compensar estas desventajas.
La idea básica es que ellas se unen para formar grandes grupos o enjambres.
Del mismo modo, en nuestro laboratorio, tratamos de crear enjambres de robots.
Y esto es todo un reto
porque ahora tienes que pensar en redes de robots.
Y dentro de cada robot,
tienes que pensar en la interacción de detección, comunicación, computación,
y esta red se vuelve muy difícil de controlar y gestionar.
Así que de la naturaleza nos llevamos 3 principios organizativos
que, básicamente, nos permiten desarrollar nuestros algoritmos.
La primera idea es que los robots tienen que ser conscientes de sus vecinos.
Tienen que ser capaces de sentir y comunicarse con sus vecinos.
Así que este video ilustra la idea básica.
Tienes cuatro robots,
uno ha sido secuestrado por un operador humano, literalmente.
Pero debido a que los robots interactúan entre sí,
sienten a sus vecinos,
que en esencia siguen.
Y aquí hay una sola persona capaz de liderar esta red de seguidores.
Así que de nuevo, no es porque todos los robots saben dónde se supone que deben ir.
Es porque sólo están reaccionando a las posiciones de sus vecinos.
(Risas)
El siguiente experimento ilustra el segundo principio de organización.
Y este principio tiene que ver con el principio de anonimato.
Aquí la idea clave es que
los robots son agnósticos a la identidad de sus vecinos.
Se les pide que hagan una forma circular,
y no importa cuántos robots se introducen dentro de la formación,
o cuántos robots se sacan,
cada robot está simplemente reaccionando a su vecino.
Es consciente del hecho de que se necesita para hacer la forma circular,
pero colaborando con sus vecinos
hace esta forma sin coordinación central.
Ahora bien, si uno pone estas ideas juntas,
la tercera idea es que esencialmente damos a estos robots
descripciones matemáticas de la forma que necesitan ejecutar.
Y estas formas pueden ser variables en función del tiempo,
y verán a estos robots comenzar a partir de una formación circular,
cambiar a una formación rectangular, estirada a una línea recta,
de nuevo a una elipse.
Y lo hacen con el mismo tipo de coordinación de fracción de segundo
que se ve en los enjambres naturales, en la naturaleza.
¿Por qué trabajar con enjambres?
Déjenme decirles de 2 aplicaciones en las que estamos muy interesados.
La primera tiene que ver con la agricultura,
que es probablemente el mayor problema que enfrentando en el mundo.
Como bien saben,
1 de cada 7 personas en la Tierra está desnutrida.
La mayor parte de la tierra que podemos cultivar ya ha sido cultivada.
La eficiencia de la mayoría de sistemas en el mundo está mejorando,
pero nuestra eficiencia del sistema de producción está disminuyendo,
debido a falta de agua, enfermedades de los cultivos, cambio climático
y un par de otras cosas.
¿Qué pueden hacer los robots?
Bueno, adoptamos un enfoque que se llama agricultura de precisión en la comunidad.
Y la idea básica es que volamos robots a través de los huertos,
y luego construimos modelos de precisión de las plantas individuales.
Así como la medicina personalizada,
mientras que uno puede imaginar tratar a cada paciente de forma individual,
lo que nos gustaría hacer es construir modelos de plantas individuales
y luego decirle al agricultor qué tipo de insumos necesita cada planta;
las entradas en este caso son el agua, fertilizantes y pesticidas.
Aquí podrán ver los robots viajar a través de un huerto de manzanas,
y en un minuto verán 2 de sus compañeros
haciendo lo mismo a la izquierda.
Y lo que están construyendo esencialmente es un mapa de la huerta.
Dentro del mapa hay uno de las plantas en este huerto.
(Zumbido de robot)
Veamos cómo se ven esos mapas parecen.
En el siguiente video, verán las cámaras que está utilizando este robot.
Arriba a la izquierda esencialmente una cámara de color destacada.
A la izquierda en el centro una cámara infrarroja.
Y en la parte inferior izquierda una cámara térmica.
Y en el panel principal, se ve una reconstrucción tridimensional
de todo árbol del huerto al pasar los sensores sobre los árboles.
Armados con información de este tipo, podemos hacer varias cosas.
Primero y posiblemente lo más importante es muy simple:
contar el número de frutas en cada árbol.
Hacer esto, le dice al agricultor cuántas frutas que tiene en cada árbol
y le permitirá estimar el rendimiento del huerto,
optimizar la cadena de producción aguas abajo.
La segunda cosa que podemos hacer
es tomar los modelos de las plantas, la reconstrucción tridimensional,
y de allí estimar el tamaño del manto,
y luego correlacionar el manto con la cantidad de área foliar en cada planta.
Esto se llama el índice de área foliar.
Si uno sabe este índice de área foliar,
esencialmente hace medición de qué tanta fotosíntesis hace cada planta,
que a su vez dice qué tan saludable es cada planta.
Mediante la combinación de información visual y de infrarrojos,
también podemos calcular índices como el NDVI.
Y en este caso en particular, en esencia se puede ver que
algunos cultivos no lo están haciendo tan bien como otros.
Esto es fácilmente perceptible a partir de imágenes,
no solo las imágenes visuales, sino combinadas
tanto imágenes visuales como de infrarrojos.
Y por último,
algo que nos interesa hacer es detectar la aparición temprana de la clorosis
--esto es un árbol de naranja--
que se ve esencialmente por el amarillamiento de las hojas.
Pero los robots pueden detectar fácilmente esto de manera autónoma
y luego informar al agricultor que él o ella tiene un problema
en esta parte de la huerta.
Sistemas como estos realmente pueden ayudar,
y estamos proyectando rendimientos mejores en alrededor de un 10 %
y, sobre todo, disminuir la cantidad de insumos como el agua
un 25 % mediante el uso de enjambres de robots aéreos.
Por último, quiero aplaudir a la gente que realmente crea el futuro,
Yash Mulgaonkar, Sikang Liu y Giuseppe Loianno,
quienes son responsables de las 3 demostraciones que vieron.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)